my dad one of their work cars got busted  into and these guys were trying to steal  it but they have these things where you  lock the wheel so every time I would  park yeah the club this thing on the  wheel and like take the key is it red  red stick and your car's not going  anywhere until you wanted to it's like  it's a club it's a club  and it's affordable  well I'm not used to that I got one  right now where are you going why is it  not on the steering wheel it was a big  90s thing to happen girl you talk about  one of these are you talking about oh  yeah this is how you know the age is so  different we grew up using these it's  the kind of protection us Pussycats need  you still use it you better put that  back on your [ __ ] car dude it's gonna  be gone much  I left that unlocked right now too  pick up the club at these stores